in a world that we'll talk about today
quite a bit which is the digital world I
think the most fascinating
philosophically and technically
definition of Life Is Life in the
digital world
so chat Bots
essentially creatures whether they're
replicas of humans or totally
independent Creations perhaps in an
automatic way
I think there's going to be chat Bots
that we would ethically be troubled by
if we wanted to kill them
they would have the capacity to suffer
they would be very unhappy with you
trying to turn them off and then there
will be large groups of activists that
will protest and they'll go to the
Supreme Court of whatever the Supreme
Court looks like in in 10 20 30 40 years
and they will demand that these chat
Bots would have the same rights as us
humans do you think that's possible I
saw that Google engineer who's basically
saying this had already happened and I I
I was surprised by it uh because it just
I when I looked at the chat logs of it
it didn't seem particularly interesting
on their hand I can definitely see I
mean gp3 for people who you know haven't
paid attention shows that serious
step-ups are possible and obviously you
know you talk about Ai and your podcast
a ton
um
is it possible that gpt9 or something is
is kind of like that or GPT 15 or gpt4
maybe
but yeah for people just listening
there's a deep skepticism in your face
yeah you know the reason being because
um you know what's possible it's
possible that you have like a partition
of society on literally this basis you
know
um that's one model where there's some
people just like there's vegetarians and
non-vegetarians right there may be
um
machines have life and machines are
machines you know like or something like
that right uh you know you could you
could definitely imagine some kind of
partition like that in the future where
your fundamental political social system
that's a foundational assumption and you
know
is AI does it you know deserve the same
rights as like a human or for example a
corporation is an intermediate uh do you
see the thing which is how human is are
different corporations have you seen
that infographic it's actually funny so
it's a spectrum there's a spectrum so
for example Disney is considered about
as human as like a dog but like Exxon I
may be remembering this wrong but they
had like a level with like human at one
end and like rock at the other does it
have to do with corporate structure what
what I think it's about people's empathy
for that Corporation their brand
identity but it's interesting to see
that first of all people sort of do
think of Corporations as being more or
like The Branding is really what they're
responding well that's what I mean
they're also responding you know I have
a brand of human that I'm trying to sell
and it seems to be effective for the
most part sure although it has become
like a running joke that I might be a
robot right which means there's the
brand is cracking because it's seeping
through but I mean in that sense I just
I think I don't see a reason why chat
Bots
can't manufacture the brand of Being
Human of being sentient I mean that is
the Turing test but it's like the
multiplayer touring test now that
actually a fair number of chat Bots have
passed a Turing test I'd say there's at
least two steps up right one is
um a multiplayer touring test where you
have chatbots talking to each other
and then you ask can you determine the
difference between in chat Bots talking
to each other and clicking buttons and
stuff in apps and and humans doing that
and I think we're very far off I
shouldn't say very very at least I don't
know how far we are in terms of time but
we're still far off in terms of
a group of n chat Bots looking like
their digital output is like the group
of Inhumans like a go from the Turing
test to the multiplayer turn test that's
one definition another definition is
you know to be able to kind of swap in
and you're not just convincing one human
that this is a human for a small you
know session you're convincing all
humans that this is a human for end
sessions remote work actually makes this
possible right that's another definition
of a multiplayer touring test where
basically you have a chat bot that's
fully automated that is earning money
for you as an intelligent agent on a
computer that's able to go and get
remote work jobs and so on I would
consider that next level right if you
could have something that was like that
that was competent enough to I mean
because everything on the computer can
be automated right literally you could
be totally hands-free just like
autonomous driving you could have
autonomous earning as a challenge
problem
if you're a Microsoft or apple and you
had legitimate access to the operating
system just like apple says can you send
me details of this event a decentralized
thing could in theory log you know the
actions of ten thousand or a hundred
thousand or a million people
and with cryptocurrency you can even
monitor a wallet that was on that
computer and you could see you know what
long run series of actions were
increasing or decreasing this digital
balance you see what I'm saying right so
you start to get at least conceptually
it'd be invasive and you know there'd be
a privacy issue and so on conceptually
you could imagine an agent that could
learn what actions humans were doing
that resulted in the increase of their
local cryptocurrency balance okay there
may be better ways to formulate it but
data considered a challenge problem is
to go from the Turing test to a genuine
intelligent agent that can actually go
and make money for you if you can do
that that's a big deal people obviously
have trading Bots and stuff but that
would be you know the next level that's
typing out emails it's creating
documents so mimic human behavior in its
entirety yeah that's right and it can
it'll schedule zooms it'll send emails
it'll essentially because if you think
about it a human is hitting the keys and
clicking the mouse but just like a
self-driving car the wheel rotates by
itself right those keys are effectively
just it's like uh like the all automator
app in in apple right
um everything's just moving on the
screen you're seeing it there and it's
just an AI it's kind of hilarious that
the I'm not a robot click thing actually
works because I I actually don't know
how that's how it works but I think it
has to do with the movement of the mouse
the timing and they know that it's very
difficult for currently for a bot to
mimic human behavior in the way they
would click that little checkbox yeah
exactly I think it's something I mean uh
again my recollection on that is it's
like a pile of Highly obfuscated
JavaScript with all kind it looks like a
very simple box but it's doing a lot of
stuff and it's collecting all kinds of
instrumentation and yeah exactly like a
like a robot is just a little too
deterministic or if it's got noise it's
like gaussian noise and the way humans
do it is just not something that you
need to be able to do without collecting
thousands and thousands and thousands of
human traces doing it but it is a
predator prey on that well and then the
computer Pavilions interested I don't
know the computer just sees the
JavaScript it needs to be able to
look outside the simulation for the
computer the world is like right it
doesn't the computer doesn't know about
the physical world so just to look
outside of its world and introspect back
on this simple box right is which is
kind of you know I think that's exactly
what mushrooms do or like psychedelics
is you get to go outside and look back
in and that's what a computer needs to
do I you know I do wonder whether they
actually give people Insight or whether
they give people the illusion of insight
uh is there a difference yeah because at
well actual Insight you know actual
Insight is
again Maxwell's equations you're able to
shift the world with that there's a lot
of practical devices that work the
illusion of insight is
I'm Jesus Christ and nothing happens
right so I don't know I think this is
quite different uh I don't know I I
think you can fake it till you make it
on that one which is
um Insight in some sense is revealing a
truth that was there all along yeah so I
mean I guess like I'm talking about
technical Insight where you you have
this is the thing you know we were
talking about actually before the
podcast like technical truths versus
political truths right some truths
they're they're on a spectrum and
there's some truths that are actually
entirely political in the sense that if
you can change the software in enough
people's heads you change the the value
of the truth for example the location of
a border is effectively consensus
between large enough groups of people uh
who is the CEO that's you know consensus
among a certain group of people what is
the value of a currency or any stock
right that market price is just the
psychology of a bunch of people like
literally if you can change enough
people's minds you can change the value
of the Border or the position the
hierarchy or the value of the currency
those are purely political truths then
all the way on the other end our
technical truths that exist independent
of whatever any one human or All Humans
think like uh the gravitational constant
right or the diameter of a virus those
those are just those exist independent
of the human mind change enough human
Minds doesn't matter those remain
constant and um
and you have things that are
interestingly in the Middle where
cryptocurrency has tried to pull more
and more things from the domain of
political truths into technical truths
where they say okay the one social
convention we have is
um that if you hold this amount of
Bitcoin or that if you hold this private
key you hold this Bitcoin and then we
make that very hard to change do you
have to change a lot of technical truths
so you you can push things
to this interesting intermediate Zone
the question is how how much of our
world can we push into that